[Applaudissements]
tireur aura été aperçu dans la zone du
port allez voir et confirmer il y a 29
victimes chacun de ces tirs a fait
mouches pas de douille
par un seul cheveu ou la moindre
empreinte
il ne veut pas mourir et il ne veut
surtout pas être retrouvé nous allons le
décevoir
le FBI n'a pas voulu tout l'évaluation
psychologique vous a fait échouer
agressive addictive et antisocial c'est
le profil des personnes qu'on emprisonne
pas qu'on engage je pense que vous avez
de l'instinct transformez-le en
carburant pour alimenter de nouvelles
théories tout de suite
ce type est dans une spirale
destructrice
genre différents certains sont vieux
d'autres jeunes
quelqu'un l'a entraîné quelqu'un l'a
aimé quelqu'un lui a vendu son arme si
on trouve ces gens on trouvera notre
garde